on ne va pas nous on est là c'est un
coup de force des syndicats ils espèrent
mobiliser un million de Français ils
étaient plutôt entre un million cent
mille et 2 millions dans les rues de la
France
[Musique]
le coup d'envoi d'une vague de
mobilisation réussie contre la réforme
des retraites
[Musique]
à Paris cheminots libraire pompier et
enseignants étaient dans la foule de
grévistes pas question d'accepter de
retarder la retraite pour ces
travailleurs quand on a commencé à
travailler tard comme moi j'ai donc je
dois avoir 43 annuités pour avoir une
retraite complète donc ça veut dire que
je partirai en retraite à 67 ans
ce qui est absolument
inique insupportable donc on est là pour
dire non mais on veut une retraite à 60
ans si la réforme des retraites est
impopulaire 68% des Français sont contre
selon un récent sondage tous n'avaient
pas envie de brandir une pancarte pour
autant aujourd'hui les enfants qui
naissent ils ont déjà une dette sur leur
tête
c'est voilà c'est tout Valérie Bollaert
est entrepreneur et la le sentiment que
le secteur public lui pourrit la vie à
force de ne pas vouloir travailler
alors ça on va tout faire pour bloquer
bloquer au nom de la solidarité d'y
tendrée lui aussi enseignant c'est
effectivement de tout faire pour montrer
ce gouvernement qu'on ne veut pas de
cette société là on ne veut pas de d'une
société égoïste une société qui partage
la richesse comme elle le partage on
veut une société fraternelle et
solidaire les retraites comme cri de
ralliement comme étincelles mais le
malaise voir le ras-le-bol et la colère
exprimée dans la rue sont loin de ces
limitée ce combat qu'on mène aujourd'hui
on est tous concernés madame même les
Canadiens aujourd'hui vous êtes
concernés vous allez à la caisse ça vous
coûte trop cher et on a du mal tous à
vivre aujourd'hui dans le monde Jérôme
Rodriguez est une figure emblématique du
mouvement des gilets jaunes il a perdu
l'oeil droit dans les manifestations
les autorités aujourd'hui redoutaient
les débordements 10000 policiers ont été
déployés dans 3500 à Paris seulement il
y a bien eu des échanges de projectiles
avec des militants de la gauche radicale
mais somme toute la violence était
contenue
son nom était sur toutes les lèvres dans
le cortège de Paris mais c'est de
Barcelone que le président Emmanuel
Macron a promis de maintenir le cap si
vous voulez que le pacte entre les
générations soit juste il faut procéder
à cette réforme et donc nous le ferons
avec respect sprit de dialogue mais
détermination et esprit de
responsabilité
déjà les syndicats tous unis pour une
même cause ce qui est rare ont annoncé
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation le
31 janvier prochain le début de quelque
chose espère-t-on reste à voir si dans
le climat d'insatisfaction générale ce
mouvement de contestation va pouvoir
s'inscrire dans la durée et provoquer un
véritable blocage du pays ici Marie-Eve
Bédard Radio-Canada Paris